I he obviously should be worried and he
is worried so he was just um he was i I
don't know just exercising some some a
peculiar sense of propriety and his
discussion with you because he's worried
and everybody's worried and more
importantly his owners are are worried
print as a model is as zetas is at a
moment in time where virtually all
assumptions about the business are
changing the assumptions about reader
habits and reader behavior changing the
assumptions about about about the nature
of advertising about about who should be
advertising about the pricing of
advertising is is changing so the idea
that that the new yorker will be a will
be around in in 25 years is is rather
preposterous and and i'll certainly
biome dinner if it is
um you know this is as as David can
exercises a certain propriety in talking
about his magazine I will probably do
the same about about mine and but but I
do think people at Vanity Fair are are
attentive to what's happening and that
in the and the the changes that are
going on and and in trying to look for
ways to to to stay on top of what's
clearly a sense of changing expectations
about about magazines and an about print
I'm now I mean one of the things and
again this is magazine I work for so I'm
not an objective here but I think one of
the things that that that Vanity Fair's
has has succeeded in in doing and it's a
lesson for all magazines is to think of
magazines as as an object which which we
curiously don't we think of magazines as
ideas and journalism and and and in
storytelling instead of as a literal
object which goes on your coffee table
which you're proud to have there